dr blast and his group of researchers
stand behind bulletproof viewing glass
they all have very serious looks on
their face that is until the first test
begins on one side of the test room a
class d subject stands holding a sheet
of paper on the other side sits a bright
red tomato on a wooden table dr blast
pushes the intercom button and speaks
into the microphone alright you may
begin d5041
nods and looks down at the sheet of
paper in his hand he begins to read is a
hippopotamus a hippopotamus or really
just a cool opponents nothing happens
d-504-1 stands there awkwardly waiting a
man next to dr blast in the observation
room snickers dr blast jerks his head
toward the researcher and stares him
down this is not a laughing matter blast
says the reprimanded researcher clears
his throat and stands up straight
sorry sir dr blast leans over and pushes
the microphone button again proceed to
the next joke d5041 the man on the other
side of the glass nods and pulls a
second sheet of paper out from behind
the first what's an archaeologist
someone whose career is in ruins says
d5041 a moment after he finishes the
joke the ripe red tomato launches itself
off the table and flies toward the face
of d-5041 the tomato is clocked at
moving 104 miles per hour d-5041 has no
time to move before the tomato slams
into his nose instantly breaking it the
men in the observation room behind the
bulletproof glass do their best to hold
back their laughter dr blast grumbles as
he jots down notes on his clipboard it
appears that scp-504 has a certain taste
in jokes he says to the rest of the
researchers in the room this elicits a
slight chuckle this might indicate
sapience i hope not clear the room and
bring in the next subject medical
personnel and a team of custodial staff
enter the room the physicians tend to
d504 one's nose and carry them out the
custodians clean the remnants of the
tomato off the floor walls and ceiling
they exit leaving the room completely
empty a moment later the door opens and
another ordinary looking tomato is
brought in and placed on the desk the
scp agent who brought in the tomato
leaves d-5042 enters the room a moment
later with a sheet of paper in his hand
he stands on the far side of the room
away from the scp-504 tomato sitting on
the table he nervously brings the paper
close to his face to read what's on it
three tomatoes are walking down the
street d-5042 says with a little shake
in his voice he had seen d5041 exit the
room just before he entered with blood
and tomato paste running down his face a
pop of tomato a mama tomato and a little
baby tomato baby tomato starts lagging
behind papa tomato gets very angry goes
over to the baby tomato and smooshes him
and says ketchup the new scp-504 tomato
immediately goes flying from the table
straight toward the joke teller this
time the tomato is clocked at 264 miles
per hour when it slams into the face of
d5042
the impact immediately renders him
unconscious after the first few trials
dr blast decides that it's time to take
things up a notch the foundation has
collected hundreds of scp-504 tomatoes
so there is no shortage after the room
is cleaned once again a medical team
removes the unconscious class-d
personnel who was knocked out by the
previous scp-504 experiment and they're
ready to begin again this time there
will be terrible consequences for their
actions
d-5043 enters the room the scp-504
tomato has already been placed on the
table you may begin dr blast says into
the microphone the class-d personnel
reads the joke on the sheet of paper
he's holding so i was going to bed and
my brother told me good night don't let
the bed bugs stick their probiscus in
your skin and suck your blood d5043
pauses for a beat good luck unhealthy
dermis he ends the joke for two seconds
there's no reaction from scp-504 dr
blast thinks this terrible joke just
wasn't one that scp-504 could understand
suddenly there's a loud crack d-5043
falls to the floor tomato covers where
his face once was when dr blast and the
other researchers go back and slow down
the video they witnessed the scp-504
tomato traveling so quickly that it
broke the sound barrier the tomato
impacted the joke teller at an
unfathomable speed instantly killing him
dr blast decides that he needs to be
more careful when choosing jokes for the
safety of everyone involved perhaps a
crossbreed between scp-504 and regular
tomatoes will yield different results
after the unfortunate death of d5043 the
research team waits a few days before
experimenting with new strains of
scp-504 three different crossbreeds are
brought into the room and placed
equidistant from each other on the table
d5044 enters the room dr blast presses
the intercom button and orders him to
begin if you have dentures don't use
artificial sweetener cause you'll get a
fake cavity says d-5044 the moment the
joke ends all three tomatoes launched
toward him at 145 miles per hour they
hit him square in the face two teeth are
dislodged and the test subject is
covered in the remains of the three
squash tomatoes interesting notes dr
blast all the tomatoes reacted in the
same way so now we know multiple
instances of scp-504 will go after the
same joke maker he pauses to think for a
moment what if we cut up the tomatoes
the test room is reset another scp-504
tomato is brought in and cut up into
quarters d-5045 enters the room and
begins his joke i tried to walk into a
target but i missed all four pieces of
the tomato speed toward d5045's face
they slam into him at 212 miles per hour
one of the pieces of tomatoes impales
itself into his eye instantly destroying
it the medical team rushes in and
removes the howling subject from the
room dr blast writes vigorously on his
clipboard we're starting to go through
test subjects too quickly he announces
let's try a recording and see if scp-504
will react to that the research team
brings in a new tomato a cd player and
the harmful if swallowed album by dane
cook the cd begins to play during one of
the jokes the tomato launches itself off
the table and slams into the cd player
causing both the stereo and the tomato
to shatter into several pieces the
tomato was clocked at 167 miles per hour
it would appear that scp-504 reacts to
the recordings as well we didn't even
have to deal with the damn class d's in
the first place says dr blast he informs
his team that since the risk level is
now relatively low they can continue the
experiments without him he leaves the
observation room to get some rest the
other researchers look at one another
mischievous smiles crossing their faces
as they begin to laugh the scp-504
research team sets up three new tomatoes
and brings three class-d subjects into
the room the researchers then retreat
back into the observation area and begin
a joke over the intercom system while
the class-d personnel wait patiently in
the room with the scp-504 tomatoes the
following news item has just been
released said one of the researchers
over the intercom bomb blows hole in
linen statue the first test subject
finishes the joke with the ending
written on his sheet of paper oh that's
going to leave remarks test subject 1
says the first tomato twitches but does
not leave its location on the table the
second test subject reads from his paper
bbc is just stalling the good news the
second tomato leaves the table at 152
miles per hour and slams into the jaw of
the second test subject causing a
hairline fracture in a chipped tooth the
third test subject looks at the ending
to the joke on his paper and begins to
shake nervously he speaks two words
which he knows will not end well for him
that blows the third scp-504 tomato
flies off the table slams into the third
test subject's head and instantly knocks
him out the test subject is sent to the
hospital with a massive skull fracture
the next day dr blast bursts into the
observation room and reprimands the
research team i thought we just
established that recordings work in
place of live subjects screams dr blast
i know how much you guys hate class d's
especially d50412 but the poor guy might
not ever recover before his termination
rolls around i'm making it clear right
now that whoever oversaw this round of
testing is getting serious reprimand the
same goes for whoever leaked its video
logs to the staff everyone is silent
from somewhere within the group of
researchers there's a snicker then they
all break out in laughter after this
incident no class d's or other personnel
are used in research being conducted on
scp-504 the research team wheels in a
television playing the sarah palin and
hillary clinton snl skit the tomato show
signs of confusion as it flies off the
table its trajectory includes three
separate bursts of speed over 200 miles
per hour two stretches of motion at
normal throwing speed and one
unprecedented instance of the tomato
moving backwards this all occurs during
the flight of a single scp-504 tomato
during the snl skit the working
hypothesis is that the tomato was unsure
whether to take the video seriously or
not the research team later finds out
that scp-504 really hates science and
mathematics jokes when they bring in a
laptop that plays a pre-recorded
engineering joke over the speakers a
mechanical voice can be heard saying
2009 is going to be a complex year we
already know the real part we still have
to find the imaginary part at the
conclusion of the joke there's a
supersonic blast and the computer is
completely vaporized by the tomatoes
kinetic energy the sensors recorded an
approximate speed of
2174 miles per hour as the tomato flew
across the room the conclusion of the
experiments on scp-504 end with another
computer being brought into the test
room the computers begin to play the
monty python sketch of the funniest joke
in the world toward the end of the skit
the allied forces are reciting the
funniest joke in the world in german to
defeat the nazis the actors chant when
at the end of the joke the tomato
explodes on the table where it once sat
debris from the tomato coats the entire
room including the computer the
researchers conclude that scp-504 did
not know what to do with the funniest
joke in the world so itself terminated
dr blast sits in the cafeteria quietly
eating his lunch reading over the logs
for the scp-504 experiments suddenly a
commotion breaks out in the kitchen
there are screams of terror dr blast
jumps out of his seat runs to the
kitchen door and pushes it open to his
surprise he sees slices of tomatoes
flying around the room someone on the
research team thought it'd be funny to
give the unknown kitchen staff scp-504
tomatoes to see what would happen after
they had been cut up and put into food
for the day someone in the kitchen told
a bad joke and the tomato slices flew
around like shrookins dr blast sees a
group of researchers peering through a
kitchen window and laughing hysterically
you'll get to the bottom of which
researchers did this and they will be
fired from the scp foundation now watch
scp-001 atonement oroboro cycle or check
out scp-5000
why the full story compilation